these people have gathered in solidarity
under a raised black power fist
for them it's symbolic of the struggle
against racism and discrimination they
say black people face daily in the
united states
the vigil is being held for dante wright
a 20 year old african-american shot and
killed by a police officer during a
routine traffic stop on sunday
his brother rejects suggestions by the
police the officer involved appeared to
intend to fire a taser not her gun
i could never understand that fear of
being pulled over by the cops
why because i am a white man i would
never understand it my brother lost his
life because they
were sugar happening like again
you know you're left from your right you
know the difference between plastic and
metal
wright spent his last moments with his
girlfriend sitting next to him in the
car
his mother was talking to him on the
phone about what to say to the police
when he was shot in the chest
the officer involved has served in the
force for 26 years
brooklyn center police chief says the
incident was a tragic error
it is my belief that the officer had the
intention to deploy their taser
but instead shot mr wright with a single
bullet
this appears to me from what i viewed
and the officer's reaction in distress
immediately after
that this was an accidental discharge
that resulted in a tragic death
of mr right
for a second night there were more
confrontations between protesters and
police
you just killed dante right
if i make a mistake are y'all gonna kill
me too
angered by repeated instances of police
brutality and racial profiling in the
u.s
hundreds of protesters defied a curfew
that started on monday
and have continued to protest despite
police using tear gas against them
the unrest comes as the trial of former
policeman derek chauvin is being held a
few kilometers away he's facing charges
of murder over the killing of george
floyd last year
some protests turned violent overnight
with several businesses looted and
damaged
president joe biden has called for peace
and calm
the question is was it an accident was
it
intentional that remains to be
determined
by a full-blown investigation but in the
meantime i want to make it clear again
there is absolutely no justification
none for looting the first black mayor
of brooklyn center has expressed his
shock
we are in pain right now
and we recognize that this couldn't have
happened at a worse time we recognize
that
this is happening at a time when our
community when all of america indeed all
of the
the world is watching
many are expecting more unrest in the
minneapolis suburb
and a state of emergency has been
declared
al jazeera well let's speak to john
hendren now who's in minneapolis for us
john looking at those pictures another
night of tear gas and rubber bullets
talk us through the mood that you're
seeing on the streets there
that's right last night despite a curfew
that went into effect at a 7 pm
local time midnight gmt
here in minneapolis in neighboring saint
paul
and in the suburban area that includes
brooklyn center
people remained out there were clashes
with
police who had to push them back with
tear gas and stun grenades those crowds
according to police
were throwing bottles and fireworks at
the officers and
you saw some of those tense
confrontations
overnight there was less of that here in
the downtown area but there is
obviously renewed anger in the streets
at the killing of another black man at
the hands of police and
it's particularly upsetting for many
people here that
this time it happened as the result
apparently
of a mistake with an officer who fired a
taser
intended to fire a taser and instead
fired her service weapon
killing dontre wright with a single
bullet
there is talk of discipline of that
officer
and of the police chief of brooklyn
center
but meanwhile the cities surrounding
this area are really
just trying to get it back into control
this is an area where
protesters of course have been active
since may 25th the death of george floyd
who's in the trial of the officer who
shot who
held his knee on george floyd's neck for
nine and a half minutes is going on in
the courthouse
behind me that will start again today
but that had already people
on edge here with that trial going on
protesters were already
gathering in the area and this just gave
them
one more thing to vent their anger about
couldn't have possibly happened
at a worse time and john as you say
today is what day 12
of the chauvin trial today and i see the
prosecution is potentially set to wrap
later on
later on today or this week
that's right we expect the prosecution
to say the prosecution rests
then begin the defense witnesses and
interestingly after about two weeks
and one day of prosecution witnesses the
judge says
he only expects three possibly four days
of defense witnesses he warned the jury
on monday that if the defense concluded
on thursday he was going to give them
friday off
but that after that on monday as soon as
opening arguments or closing arguments
rather started
he was going to sequester or isolate
them so that they would not be subject
to the vast public opinion on
all of the media that you see here
locally so
that is going to happen starting monday
that also encourages them to come to the
end of their deliberations soon but
now we're waiting for the defense and we
expect them to come up with medical
witnesses and police witnesses
to refute the prosecution case that
derek chauvin
unjustifiably killed george floyd
john hendren there in minneapolis for us
with all the latest thank you so much
john